[Music]
kyle is with us
kyle's in amarillo hi kyle how are you
hi i'm good good how can we help
so my question was how does okay so like
how does a spender
learn how to get in the habit of saving
just because
i i love to spend i have a habit of just
spending and spending and spending
and i'm since now that i'm 19 i got to
get in the habit of
saving while i'm young instead of
keeping that habit of spending spending
spending
okay well i'm a spender too so i can
relate to that are you a spender saver
you're a spender
i'm a spender you're a spender yeah
sheila's a saver yeah so
um there's a couple of things you need a
reason
to do it a why
and right now you don't really have a
reason other than this feels like it's
wrong
but uh when i went broke and i had to
learn
okay i know i'm not a natural saver but
saving money seems wise versus being
broke
which is kind of what you're saying kyle
right and so how do i do that
well what i figured out was most
spenders too by the way are generous
are you fairly generous yes i love
being generous okay so what i figured
out is if i invest and save
i have more money to spend and more
money to be generous with
so it's like i i have a reason now to
save
and to systematically save to become
wealthy because i can
increase my generosity and i can
increase my enjoyment with spending
and so i can spend now and not think
anything about it
versus spending and having this like
financial hangover the next morning
wake up with a headache and go what did
i do last night practically speaking
kyle
there's been seasons in my marriage
where i literally give
my debit card to my wife because i take
cash and put my wallet so when it's gone
i it is gone you set yourself a system
to protect you from you put barriers in
front of me
until uh it's like bumper lanes at the
pool and
i mean when you're uh bowling i'm sorry
not to pull when you're bowling so that
i can learn
i i need these these guardrails and
that's me as a grown-up
i should know better partner with a phd
in psychology i've got to put some
barriers in
in front of me so that i can get myself
back on put systems in your life that
help you uh stay tuned
to your goal right and uh you know and
and so okay my goal is uh i i want to
be in that be a be a spender that's who
i am
but i want to do that with it with
wisdom and
i my goal is i want to be a saver so
what do you do
to what has to be true to cause that to
happen and you know an example would be
an
auto draft uh out of your checking
account
directly into a mutual fund that
automatically
saves for you see that's a system that
turns you into a saver
because you might not remember to do it
that's why you tell people to cut up the
credit card so you can't
right chop them up that's right surgery
the same thing works
for um your marriage right i got a few
buddies that a hundred percent of the
time they call
they will i know they're gonna ask hey
man how's your marriage
are you how y'all doing and there it's
it's again it's a it's an accountability
it's a check in how are things going i
know that's going to happen every time
we call right
and so it's having setting up those
systems in your life that none of us are
perfect not all of us are trying to
figure it out and
but i know where i want to go so i know
i've got to have these accountability
systems in my life
i'm so much of a spender that i used to
think when you were leaving costco or
sam's and they check your receipt
that they were checking to see if you
really spent two hundred dollars
no you were you want to know if you won
that day
would you check see if i wanted to
scratch off the biggest one just the
biggest one today
no dave sorry i gotta go but yeah i feel
like if you don't spend two hundred
dollars they got they point the finger
back into the building and go
go get the six gallons a month there was
a family of you need six gallons of
mustard
everyone needs six gallons of mustard
and you're not up to your 200
go back in there